So, something has really been bothering
me. It is that when I look at my new
content, it has all of this vibe of
accepting yourself more, uncovering
repressed emotions, becoming more whole.
And then when I look at the content that
got me big on YouTube, content that was
extremely valuable for you guys, the
audience, I find things like banish
helplessness and hunt your fear and kill
your own embarrassment. The opposite of
what I'm talking about today. And when I
look in terms of concrete charisma
advice, I see things like lines that for
me and for the audience were extremely
helpful when I was dealing with social
anxiety. There's one that is etched, I
think, into my lyic system. Like, if I
were on my deathbed, I'm pretty sure I
could recite this despite the fact that
I'd be delusional. And it's, "Hey, this
is totally random, but I just saw you
walking down the street, and I'd be
kicking myself for the rest of the day
if I didn't come find out more about
you." That is just in there. And yet
today, when I talk about women and dates
and what needs to happen, it has very
little to do with lines. So, there's
obviously this split between what helped
me learn charisma the first time and
where I am with charisma today. And I
want to address that in this video and
help you to find out which version of me
or anyone you should listen to with
regards to charisma or any other area of
your life that you're trying to improve.
Because there's multiple stages to
learning anything. And if you don't know
where you are in this stage, there's
four of them. you're going to have a
hard time actually assimilating the
advice and getting better and you might
even go backwards. So here's the deal.
The first stage, and I'm borrowing this
four stage framework from Michael
Beckwith, is the victim stage. It's the
two me stage. You're in this with
regards to charisma if you think that
there's nothing that you can do. You
don't think you can change your
charisma. You don't think you can change
your confidence. It's just something
that the attractive, tall, handsome, fit
people have and you don't have it
because you are not that. This is an
acutely painful stage because it is all
about avoiding responsibility and
placing blame. But that's also the
benefit of the stage is you don't have
to do anything. So if you want to help
someone, if you're in my position,
you're trying to help someone in this
stage. Often times what they need is a
swift kick in the butt as well as some
very concrete things that they can
implement immediately and find that they
have agency, they have control. So this
is where concrete lines like say this
when you're in an elevator and you meet
someone for the first time or say this
to your boss or say this to someone that
you're wanting to date. If they can use
that and get a slightly better response
from that person or even a majorly
better response, this is can transform
the arc of their life. Now they realize
that they have control over this area
that was previously just about blame and
avoiding responsibility. And that'll
take them into stage two. Stage two is
the buy me stage. This is where you
start to realize, "Holy cow, I can
control this. I'm not just faded to be
the shy introvert that I know I was when
I was in middle school and high school
and even the beginning of college. I
have agency here." And this is where you
start learning lines, implementing them,
building out decision trees of what you
can say. It gets more and more complex.
And as you go through this, you might do
other areas of your life. It might be
fitness. It might be finances. What
you'll find is that the lines give way
to habits, to modes of being, and to
mindsets. And this is where things like
my six charismatic mindsets come in. It
is much easier to hold, no matter what,
I will be okay than it is to walk in
with a full decision tree of lines that
you can say in any situation. And yet at
stage two, you retain everything that
you've learned up until then. So still,
you'll have that line that I have in my
head. When a pretty girl walks past and
you don't know what to say, boom, it's
in there. So you don't lose the thing
that came before, but you hold it in a
wider container. And honestly, this is
what most of self-help is. This is what
a lot of the Charisma on Command YouTube
channel has been, but it was starting to
tilt towards stage three before I left.
And especially now that I'm back,
because it doesn't stop there. And by
the way, cutting in from the future
here, it is worth mentioning that if you
are someone who is either in stage one
or stage two, the thing that I made that
is most helpful is Charisma University.
That's our online course. It's a 30-day
program that is really intended to help
you take full control over your charisma
and your confidence in your social life.
We've had a lot of people go through it
that have had life-changing results.
I'll post a few of them here. But if
that's something that interests you and
you're still in this stage, I highly
recommend checking it out because it's
basically the best thing that I can make
at that stage. I don't think I'll ever
be able to do anything like it again.
Anyway, that's that if you want to check
it out. Link is in the description
below. As you start to get more and more
control over more and more areas of your
life, you'll find that something is
missing, right? You can This is the
person who gets everything they want.
They get the girlfriend. They get the
job. They get the husband, they get the
acclaim and the status and the fortune.
And they feel empty. And it's because
that what was leading them in that stage
of their life was their ego. And it was
a wonderful leader for a long time. It
led them to incredible results. But what
the ego wants is not what your heart
wants. It's not what your soul wants.
And at some point, you have to open up
to something bigger than what you can
concoct in your mind. And this is the
scary leap where you go from grabbing
control stage one to two to releasing
control again. And this is terrifying
for people in stage two because what got
them everything so far in their life is
grabbing on to control and taking
agency. So to give it up here is really
scary. But you're not giving it up to
that blaming lack of responsibility
aspect of yourself in stage one. You're
giving it up to something larger than
you. And if you don't know exactly what
this is, I promise you have felt it at
one point in your life. Any time that
you entered the flow state, you were in
the through me stage. Stage three,
whether you're playing sports, taking a
test, having a conversation,
when you just start playing better than
you're ever capable, and you're saying
things you've never heard yourself say,
and you're making moves or dribbling or
shooting in a way that is beyond what
you even practiced, that's the through
me stage. Something more intelligent is
moving through you. And yes, all the
practice that you did in order to get
there is necessary, but it's almost the
way that you're crafting this instrument
that then something more intelligent
than you can play and move through. And
this is really what the best improv
comedians are doing. They are not coming
on planning the best joke beforehand.
They are doing everything that they can
to get out of their way on stage so they
can be 100% present in the moment with
the audience, with their co-worker or
whatever the heck they're called in
improv comedy, their co- troop on the
stage so that they can drop into the
moment and say something funnier than
they'd ever imagined, than they ever
could have planned. And so that is stage
three is when you start to surrender to
something higher than yourself. This is
all about wholeness. This is what I've
been creating lately on the YouTube
channel where you go back and you find
that, oh wow, in stage two, I cut off
all these pieces of myself. I cut off my
fear. I cut off my embarrassment. I
excluded my shame. In stage three, you
start to let go, recover that, and find
that it comes back with gifts. Now, that
might all sound very fancy and very
poetic, but I promise you, it gets
weirder and more poetic as you move into
stage four. And admittedly, this is not
one that I've spent a lot of time in.
It's one that I've touched. I think that
most of us have touched it. You're
sitting in nature. It's quiet and the
boundaries between you and the trees and
the sounds and the animals just seem to
dissolve. Sometimes this can happen in
psychedelic experience where the sense
that you are separate from life from the
universe just falls away because stage
four is the as me stage. Life is you.
And charisma takes on a very different
meaning in this stage because you're no
longer trying to be special to get
things to happen for you or to you. It's
all you. So getting to just witness and
sit back and experience what happens and
moving increasingly only from a deep
sense of stillness. That's what begins
to happen at stage four. And if you
think of the most charismatic people
throughout history, Jesus, the Buddha,
these are stage four individuals. These
are people whose charisma shaped eons,
thousands and thousands of years. People
who are generations away from them are
still moved and touched by stories of
what they did. That is an incredible
form of charisma, but it's not them
steering it. It's not even something
moving through them. It is them as life.
So, what to do with all of this? Well,
I've been wrestling with this because I
find myself with my gravity regarding
charisma and many other things in life
in stage three. It's this receptive,
surrendering, feminine letting go that
has come after 10 plus years of
assertive masculine controlling stage
two. And what that means is that I'm
unable to make content as frequently as
I would like because this is my edge.
I'm learning this. But this framework
has really helped me because as I was
going back and reading my own blog posts
and watching these videos and
recognizing this is still so helpful.
And the last thing that I want to do is
get in the way of my old self or
somebody who is in the place that I was
by insisting that they respond to where
I am today. Honestly, that's selfish.
It's me cutting stage two out in the
same way that stage two cuts stage one
out. Every stage says the stage that
they came from is wrong and bad. And I
think maturity is in realizing no, we're
all on different parts of our journey
and there are similarities. So what I
want to do with this is one to help you
identify where you are in this journey.
Now to be clear, you can be different
areas and different aspects of your
life. But with regard to charisma, where
are you? Are you someone who has
probably not the case if you're watching
this, but not taking full ownership that
you have agency, right? You just are
what you are and you can't become more
confident. You can't work on your social
skills. You just need to get bigger,
stronger, and make more money. and
that's the only way that anybody could
respond any differently to you. Or are
you in stage two, right? You've learned
a couple of lines. You've got some
skills. You've begun to master this. You
feel like you're in control of this and
you're just optimizing. Stage three,
maybe you're starting to let go, to
really, really develop a capacity to
listen. Not to listen for what you
should say, but to listen to what is
needed in the moment, what is being
called out and asked for from a state of
presence. Or stage four. Honestly, I
can't even describe that one because I
don't live there all the time. Maybe one
day I'll make that video. So, identify
where you are, number one. But number
two, what I want to do is release more
content. And the only way for me to do
that is to accept that I'm going to have
to make some content that is for stage
one and stage two people because I have
that that is in me. I know it. And
sometimes make the stage three stuff as
well. So, starting in September, I'm
building out the processes. What I want
to do is to have either in the pinned
comment or here on the side of the
video, we'll figure out where some sort
of a visual of a ladder that will signal
to you guys who this video is for.
There's no judgment. There's nothing
wrong. But I just don't want to have
that confusion of, "Wait a second,
Charlie. In the last video, you said
that I should let everything go. Drop
the lines. Center into the deep self,
the thing that Dr. K and Joe Hudson and
I talked about on the podcast two weeks
ago. And now this week you're telling me
wait 3 seconds of silence and then use
this line. Like which of it is it? I
just want to know and be clear who I'm
talking to because each of those have
value at different stages in the journey
and they're four different people at
different times. So that's it. Just want
to leave you with that. I look forward
to coming out with more content and I'm
very excited. You have questions,
comments, anything, just leave them in
the comments below. Love you guys and
I'll catch you later. Peace.